hey guys its benefits of a G from GE
tracker and in this video I want to talk
about decanting potions because this
seems to be a popular choice amongst
some of you guys and for good reasons to
it's not a money maker that you'll sit
at the grand exchange and you know wait
for the item to buy but rather this is
something that you'll do while you do it
while you do other activities so for
instance right now I'm buying super
restores because based off on the chart
there's a lot of people buying this
potion at a four dose and right now I'm
just doing some quest while I'm waiting
for these autumn to buy so i can let
that flip while i'm doing something else
and that's what i suggest you guys do as
well but before we get into this video
why don't we go to our winner from a few
weeks back when we had our one of our
herb lore videos where it was a giveaway
for bonds how my finally met up was one
of our winners so one we cut to that
real quick alright guys so I'm actually
recording over this video that I made
earlier too because I was a little
caught off guard I was watching the dead
night mode tournament while I was room
crafting and then the guy logged in so I
quickly scrambled to try and record the
video but you know little off guard and
I was also doing some laundry and so you
lose a lot of outside noise and so but
we finally met up with jiggies all from
as one of our winners from a couple
weeks ago wat in that hurdler video and
based on what he's wearing I think no I
think he needed is a little bit more
than our last winner not to say anything
bad about our last one or this guy but
you know I hope this guy uses the bond
to the best of his ability you know hope
he makes the most out of it and he says
gonna play dead men boat so you know
good luck to that guy
let's go back into our our other video
on decanting potions alright guys so
this is what your decamp oceans tool is
going to look like and you can find this
again under your money making section
and it's gonna be the second link now
the reason I want to talk about this
tool is because this has been something
that's been a little bit more popular
recently with you guys but also some of
you guys have also been losing money on
this and I want to stress the importance
of making sure you're picking potions
are going to be profitable for you now
what am I what do we mean by that I mean
picking a potion that's always going to
be in use so if we look if we click on
the approximate profit justice any other
table with this site if you click on
this it's going to show you from the
least the highest so it's for me the
least profitable to and high profile and
if I click it again I'll show me the
highest to lowest now if I knew nothing
about this game and I stumbled upon this
tool and it's showing me of that I can
make 4100 potion we may keep in mind how
much of this is being traded at any
given point in time you know that's what
we have our buying and selling quantity
columns right here for you guys to see
how much this is being floated around
and trying to action wise and as we can
tell here that there's no question marks
on this item indicating that this this
value isn't really know
with a question mark that means that
that price might be a little bit more
volatile now you have to use a little
bit of logic in this for the more
experienced places a brand new player
who stars as games not going to know
this but for someone who's been playing
this for at least like a year you have
to use logic how many times ball players
game have you ever bought 100 potion
probably never for me personally I
bought at one time to complete our stuff
on a clue scroll one time and I couldn't
even self back I literally just dropped
it on the floor so that's something to
pay attention to you have to pay
attention to the transaction volume okay
there's not a lot of people buying this
and if we click on this real quickly
it's going to further prove that so you
know the buying selling ratio is really
low and if we go down here for the
amount traded click on the day graph
it's going to show us that there's not
really that many people buying this at
any given point in time and it's barely
hitting you know above 150 which really
doesn't give us a lot of room to try and
make any profit off of this now if we
now how do we pick an item that we knows
and need the man how do we how do we be
more selective and try and figure out
which item would be best to decant well
personally for me I like to see which
item is being bought more than others so
then I would click on this column here
for buying quantity to show me the
highest baht per hour to the lowest pop
now right off the bat it's showing me
that the prior potion has a huge demand
almost double that of the next potion
below it
and as we can tell there's more people
buying this than there is selling it so
right off the bat and know if I were to
have the Prairie potion and decant it
and I wanted to sell it for dose of this
I should have no trouble whatsoever
getting it off my hands but another
problem that I see with some of your
users is that you're trying to look at
this table at face value and that's
wrong when you're looking at this table
here you shouldn't think well okay the
one dose is showing me I can buy this
for this much and I can sell it back for
dose for this much the problem with that
is the markets always changing so you
never really know how much these atoms
are going Porter and these are really
just guidelines to show you how like
recently this is what these items were
averaging to sell at now if we click on
the photos potion
again we're going to give us a list of
data based on a guideline on where we
should expect this potion to be selling
and buying for and again is showing us a
positive buy sell ratio which is
indicating that there's more people
buying this that are selling it so I
shouldn't struggle at this point current
time to try and get this item off my
hands now if we look down here it's
going to become pretty apparent that the
price does change all the time okay so
you shouldn't look at these values and
think okay well I should expect to sell
it for this and you know buy it back for
that it just doesn't happen the price or
rice is always changing so you need to
pay attention to this stuff and I've
already gone and I've already gone over
in different videos on this on the
pricing graph and how to look at this
what were you may have noticed is that
we change the we've changed just a
little bit this was a recent update that
I'm not going to go into but if you want
to look at the previous rising graphics
what it was it was going to be the
linear algorithm and this is something
that you guys were seeing before which
didn't really show too much information
but now we're sitting it as a default
for the log on the rhythm okay so that's
pretty cool I'm not going to go into
that and as we look if we look at the
trading volume down here we can see that
it's pretty consistently sold and bought
all the time at a much higher volume
than the hunter potion okay the hundred
potion didn't even hit a thousand but on
during the day at any given point in
time it's sold a lot you know it's it's
a very useful item and it's always going
to circulation all the time okay so if
we wanted to
let's say we wanted to use this potion
how do we add this to our transaction so
we can add this to a profit tracker and
keep track of how much we're making
while using this tool well as a default
we're set on the overview tab here which
will show us all these potions here for
that information that you need but once
you've decided which potion you want to
pick then you can go to the calculator
and then you can you can see the list of
options here of all the potions
available for you to buy now since the
table was showing us that the Prairie
potion at the time of this recording has
a higher transaction of buyers with a
positive buyer seller a shield this is
something that I would want to pick
because it's still profiting okay but
one thing to keep in mind is that just
because I'm showing a prayer potion
doesn't mean later on this is something
that's gonna be profitable for you guys
you should always check with the table
to make sure whichever item that you
guys are picking is profitable there's
always people buying that item at the
four toes potion now what you may have
noticed right off the bat is when I
clicked on a potion one of these columns
here one of these rows started to
highlight in green okay that's going to
let me know which of these which of
these robes is the cheapest dose option
but but what's even more important is to
look at the buying and selling per hour
now at the beginning of this video I was
um I was showing you guys that I was
working on a quest and I was doing other
things now when I look at this I'm
saying that there's really not a lot of
people buying or selling this at any
given point in time it's smaller than
the hunter potion or even comparison
comparing to that so if I were to buy a
tutto sprayer potion
I could do one of two things I could
either you know start including a
variety of lips in my transaction so i
might invest a little bit of my cast
icon prior potions to decant and then i
might invest other money on other items
so i can wait on this as well so if this
private potion wasn't buying as quickly
as i wanted i still have other items
that i can flip and make money in the
meantime or as a combination is that you
can you know flip with other items as
well and do other activities and game
for me personally i was i was questing
in game okay and if we look here it's
going to show us what this item is
currently buying at so if i were to buy
a two-dose potion this is what i could
expect it to buy up and this is what i
could expect it to sell it but it's not
a fine not answer this isn't a
black-and-white answer and what you will
or where you will buy this for and what
you will sell it for so if you go on
game and you see that you that you try
testing out and you try buying one of
these and it didn't turn out as well as
you wanted it and you bought it for 45
52 or something like that and you sold
it back for 9,000 it's going to let you
know if you bought one of these did you
profit or lose money on this and right
now with those changes I actually and
still profiting which is really cool
okay know what happens if I change this
to I don't know something like 40 80 or
let's actually look quite a little bit
bigger bigger than that okay now it's
showing me that I should expect a loss
on this so if I were to buy 100 of these
I'm going to lose twenty thousand
dollars or 20,000 GP around that area if
I were to try and buy it for this price
and sell back at this price now what if
we were lucky enough to buy it at 4,400
and sell it for
I knew 100 these are just examples and
I'm using random numbers because I don't
want you guys trying to replicate what
I'm doing here no this is just as an
example for you guys on how to use this
tool and how to go about it okay just
picking random numbers just show you how
this works ok so it's showing me if I
buy any motherless with this current
price that I've entered I should expect
a profit now if i want to buy I don't
know 4,000 at ease it's going to let me
know right here and the line cost how
much of an investment that would be so
if I would buy four thousand prayer
potions out of to dos but this price I'm
going to be investing 17.6 million on
this investment alone okay and then I
should expect to make back 600,000 now
to add this to your Chad this year your
transactions all you have to do is click
Add transaction automatically it's going
to bring you to your active transaction
page and it's going to put it right here
automatically for your active sales okay
so if you were to complete this and it
was all done and all done you just
remember to complete transactions and
it's didn't win but since I didn't
actually buy this I'm just going to go
ahead and delete that okay so yeah
that's the so that's how you use the
decamp oceans tool guys and I wanted to
talk about this because this is
something that's been popular recently
with you guys and I want to stress the
fact that this isn't something where
you're going to sit at the grand
exchange and you know wait for these
flip or wait for these to buy this is
something that you would normally you
know do something else like I said
earlier but if you guys have any
suggestions on any future videos on what
you guys want to see
you know leave a comment down below or
you know let me know in the comment or
let me know in this court you guys ping
me because it's just ping me like this
oh wait there you go it would let me
know if you just entered my name here it
would let me know that you know you're
trying to get my attention and the tight
contact me and if you want to contact
james you do the same thing for james so
would just be at james ok so that's how
you use this potion guys thank you so
much for the support so guys so far be
sure to leave a like down below if you
guys like this video you guys want to
see future videos like this leave a
comment down below and what you guys
want to see be sure to subscribe to see
any future content go look merging and
until next time guys
[Music]
you